I think our patient is waking up. Now you better be gentle with them. Last time you made
the specimens heart rate go to 160 beats per minute which is outrageous. All while they
were lying down made I add. Humans are resilient but not perfect. They have obvious limitations.
You should make better notes when working directly with them. It also lowers aggressiveness
overall. There was that other incident where you resorted to using your tentacles to restrain
them and you were left with a nasty mark for a while until you're newly married to heal it.
No they missed out often but there is a reason I ask you to be a part of this particular humans
induction. In the case report here it says they didn't even resist. Looks like they are a deep
sleeper. Or some kind of insomnia. Or if they do find you get to sleep. It's so deep. They have no clue
what's going on around them. How fascinating. They can't just turn it on like a switch or a timer.
What intricate little things they make for their daily lives. It can't seem to fix themselves.
A shame. Well hopefully they will soon learn our ways are superior. Oh they're awake now.
Hello dear specimen. Please do not pull on the first strange. That is fuel that will just
allow you to your heart rate. Relax. You are safe and in a serialized lab for lack of better words.
We are just running some boring guinea pig test on you and then from there you will be infected
with our virus and back to mingle with your own. Oh don't worry we are testing how rapidly humans
can be infected so if it doesn't go too well it's not like you failed. If anything the results are
very valuable or well they are to us anyway. With a little bit more bedside manners that
wasn't bad I think you will be fined to conduct some of these experiments on your own.
First human we do have to take some samples so that we have a baseline from when you started
and where you are in a month's time. Oh yeah we do have to recapture you but don't worry
you already have a tracker in you. We will be watching over you the whole time almost like an
angel. You humans do love the idea of something watching over you even if they are powerless but
this time well something very strong and powerful is caring for you. Who comforted and
trained you think? Let me just check over you real quickly.
It looks pretty alright to me.
Let me just prepare them for you.
Okay it's time to infect them. This one turned one bit I promise.
Our technology is unsprisingly a lot more advanced than you think. However the side effects are
rather curious. Most humans explain it like a weird lucid dream but it's rather favorable
due to the fact not a single soul will believe you when you explain this experience in detail.
How amazing.